We want the user to be able to
toggle between viewing set memes
as a collection and
viewing them as a table.
We'll do this using
a tab bar controller.
Tab bar controllers
are fairly straight forward,
let's practice by setting up
the Bond Villian's app using tabs.
Here I've got the Bond Villian's app
with the master detail structure and
I'm going to drag in
a tab bar controller.
The tab bar controller comes
automatically connected to two items.
I don't need those though, so
I'm going to go ahead and delete them.
I'll connect the tab bar
controllers first tab by dragging
from the connections menu.
Here under triggered segues to the
navigation controller for my table view.
Next up, we'll connect
the collection view controller.
Here you can see I've added the
Villain Collection View Controller for
showing bond villains in a grid.
And I've assigned it as the root
ViewController to this second navigation
controller.
I'll connect the second tab to
the navigation controller for
the collection view, again, by dragging
from the ViewController segues
in the tab bar controllers
connections menu.
And then once I've got the tab
bar controller all connected up,
I want to make sure that it's set
up as the initial ViewController.
Which I can do here in
the attributes inspector.
And then we'll run it.
Okay, there's our table, and
we can toggle to a collection and
back to a table.
Alright.
And if you want to change the appearance
of the bar items, you just go back into
Storyboard, click on the bar item in its
respective navigation controller, and
then in the attributes inspector,
you can change the title [SOUND]
or you can add an image.